Speaker 1: All right. I briefly want to talk
about one other aspect of so-called vaccine
mandates. I've said for a while I think it
should be required to fly in the United States
airlines governed by the federal Department
of Transportation. It should be required to
be vaccinated, to fly. I say this less
because of the spread on airplanes,
but more because it seems from the
polling we have that being vaccinated,
being a requirement to fly. Would
actually convince a lot of people to go
and get vaccinated and this is becoming more
and more of a topic over the last few days,
NBC News reports that Dr. Anthony Fauci would
support a vaccine mandate for air travel. Now, as
you may know, some airlines are requiring vaccines
for workers but have not mandatory mandated
it for passengers. The nation's leading infectious
disease expert, Dr. Anthony Fauci, said he would
support a covid vaccine mandate for traveling on
airplanes. I would support that. If you want to
get on a plane and travel with other people, that
you should be vaccinated, he said in a clip of an
interview with the SKIMS podcast. The U.S. Travel
Association Monday responded to Fowkes comment,
saying science and studies show air travel
is safe as long as facemasks are worn.
U.S. travel has long maintained there should
be no mandatory vaccination requirements
for domestic travel, this would have an
unfair negative impact on families with
young children not yet eligible. Well, you can
always exempt young children. That's not a good
argument. Let's listen to what Dr. Fauci said.
Speaker 2: If we get the overwhelming proportion
of the population vaccinated, we will get to herd
immunity. If we do it in the next six months,
it will happen in the next six months. If
we do it in the next two months, it will
happen in the next two months. I would support
that. If you want to get on a plane and travel
with other people, that you should be vaccinated.
When you hear us say should you mandate.
Speaker 1: OK, so now they're going on to another
topic. I've got to tell you, I am 100 percent in
favor of this. And again, it's not because
airplanes are the number one point of spread.
It's because so many people have said a
hundred bucks is not going to convince me to
get back vaccinated. Even my employer saying
I've got to get vaccinated or test weekly.
That's not going to get me to get vaccinated. But
in a number of polls now, we've seen that as many
as 41 percent of those not yet vaccinated say if
it became a requirement to get on an airplane,
I would go and get vaccinated. That's
why it is not about the spread on planes,
but about what we can do to get people
vaccinated. We also have data about
people want that Forbes article. Most
Americans now want vaccine mandates for planes,
hotels and restaurants per Gallup. In the four
months between April and August, as the Delta
variant swept across the US, support for travel
related vaccine mandates ticked noticeably upward.
More than six in 10 Americans now support
requiring proof of full vaccination before
getting on a plane, up from 57 percent.
Support for vaccine mandates for hotel guests
reached a majority status in August,
notching up nine percent from 44 to 53.
The largest shift on vaccine mandates involves
eating out. Between April and August, there was
a 13 percent jump in support for having to show
proof of vaccination status before dining in a
restaurant. 53 percent of Americans now support
it, compared to only 40 percent four months ago,
and 58 percent now support a vaccine mandate
for going to large events like concerts and
festivals. This is the vaccine requirements to
fly. Popular among Americans, not a reason to do
something Americans might want something that's
a bad idea, but popular among Americans and
admitted to by the anti-war AXA's that
if it was required to get on a plane,
they would go and get themselves vaccinated,
many of them and supported by Dr. Fauci. I
would like to see this. It is now known it is
being considered by the Biden administration.
I hope that it will be enacted soon. If you
disagree with me, let me know. We'll have more
coverage of this story on The David Pakman Show
Instagram, which you can find at David Pakman show